how about yourself kyah um oh i got so
many nice things for christmas yes i did
but
the best thing about christmas is being
here with you guys i'm feeling very
festive i'm feeling very festive and uh
you should have went to santa hats
we should wear santa hats today actually
well um who's going to be wearing the
santa half
hatch after the first round of the air
things masters these are
their results after round one and all
games
except one ended in draws but hikaru
nakamura was able to beat alexander
grishard
in that first game such a good start for
the american yucca yeah definitely
hikaru of course
you know he's had so many near misses
you know he's ended up in the finals
semi-final but he's never ever won
so definitely this will be a promising
start for him
the best start for hikaru nakamura and
that means that he is
on top of the table after round one we
will have
11 rounds of round robin in the
preliminaries before we go to the court
file so
ikar nakamura a great start for him
and well david